Instructor: A really
great use case for spreads is
when you spread into a function.
Now, let's take a look at this
example. I've got my inventors
array right here, and I want to
take the items from New
Inventors and put them into
Inventors. I don't want a third
array. I don't want to overwrite
the entire array. I just want to
tack them onto the end. You
might think, "OK, we'll just
take the inventors and we'll
call push on it, and we'll pass
it the new inventors." Let's see
what that gives us. Console.log
Inventors, now we get three
items, and then we have the
fourth item is an array of two
things. That's inside it. That's
not what we want. We
essentially just did this. We
took the array and added it as a
fourth item, so we have an array
in an array. We don't want that.
A way that you could have solved
this in the past is inventors.
push, and then you call the
apply on it, and you pass it
this context, which is inventors,
and you pass it. That will work,
and I'll tell you why. There we
go. What's happening here is
when you call apply, it's going
to run the function that you
called apply against, but every
single item of the array as an
argument. It's essentially
doing this, .push, musk, and
jobs, because you can't pass
push an array. You can pass push
as many arguments as you wish.
That's a little bit funky, and
I've seen a lot of people
scratch their heads looking at
something like that, where you
have Inventors twice, and then
you call this weird apply thing
on it? It's a little bit hard to
actually understand. Rather
than that, what we can do is you
just simply call push, and we
only pass it the New Inventors.
Again, let's see the issue that
we get with that. That's the
array, but if you were to spread
into it, what does spread do?
Spread is going to take musk and
jobs to pass it as individual
argument into push. Now we don't
have to worry about any of that
ply, or this, or any of these
things. We simply just
spread right into the functions.
We've been spreading into arrays,
but you can also spread into a
function where every single item
of the array is going to be used
as an argument. Let's build
another example ourselves where
we have a function that says, "
Say hi." It's going to have a
first name and a last name, and
we're simply just going to alert, "
Hey there first." What am I
doing? Let's use a template
string. "Hey there first and
last." We're going to do a
really simple thing. Then I
have someone's name, so const
name is an array Wes and Bos.
For whatever reason, we've got
an array, and we need to pass
argument one, argument two. You
could do this. Say, "Hi." Then
you say, "Name 0And "Name 1."
That should work. OK. "Hey
there, Wes Bos," but that
doesn't really work that well,
especially if you had a whole
bunch of arguments that you need
to pass in. What we could do
instead of passing the two
individual arguments is you just
spread the array, and that will
pass "Wes" as the first argument
and "Bos" as the second argument.
Then you say, "Hey there, Wes
Bos," without having to do any
of that weird square bracket
stuff. Spreading into a
function, very, very handy.